[Applause]
these were beautiful homes nestled in
the trees of a desirable lakeside
community but in just a few minutes fire
ruled through showing no mercy this is a
beautiful spot here unlike most mark
Walker didn't flee he risked his own
life to protect as many of his
neighbor's homes as he could do you
regret staying yeah I regretted irony of
course do I have a whelmed every morning
what's happened you know I'm just in
disbelief you know because I lived and
you know everybody says to me you're
here oh you saved their house and you
did this and what I feel like that I
just what did something really really
stupid
I stayed Roberts has lived here for 35
years he left but his home is still
standing because of mark well what do
you think we do you think them good
neighbor sorry but as residents return
in disbelief they soon realized nothing
can be salvaged scores of homes were
destroyed and with more communities in
the line of fire
Mark's message is simple go just get in
the car and go just go you know it's
coming this is what's coming it's just
this is it and there is no escaping it
if you're somewhere unless you're
standing here in the middle of the road
where there's nothing around here 400
meters you are totally vulnerable homes
can of course be rebuilt but the real
tragedy is two people died here one was
a parish councilor killed in the
neighborhood hit dedicated so much of
his spare time trying to improve